foreign
in Denver let's what's up Maria
hello John I am very very nervous don't
don't
be you're good
haven't lost a patient yet what's up
actually you're not my patient but you
know what I mean what's up
so I am 25 years old with three kids
holy smokes that lead divorced
why yeah why'd you get divorced
um we were high school sweetheart we
um I know I'm jealous
I'm jealous I don't know so
it's a very weird scenario we didn't
quite know each other when I ended up
pregnant okay
um she ended up being a prom baby so
um awesome I know great and then three
months after I found out I was pregnant
I quite didn't know his family because
again it was kind of an oop and we
barely knew each other
um he left for the military so
I had to go through the pregnancy pretty
much by myself up until two months prior
to me delivering the baby I had to get
to know his family all by myself
so that was great
um was it wasn't Maria was it girl was
it great
mother-in-law
the year is one
okay
all right so you've got three kids three
little ones five and two Holy Smokes on
a stick all right so eight five and two
yes I got one kid asking you about sex
and you've got one kid who's still
babbling about in diapers and a
five-year-old who doesn't even know what
day it is so okay and you recently
divorced how recently is your divorce
finalized
um two months ago oh jeez it took about
a little over a year yeah Denver's the
worst man Colorado's the worst
yeah it got it got nasty lawyers
yes everything
um he accuses me of blind signing him
and that I messed him up and that
like he never seen it coming but yet we
did marriage counseling for a year and a
half
ultimately why'd you leave
um I was very alone
I pretty much did everything
you've been alone for a long long you've
been alone since you were in high school
right
long long time
sorry I get very emotional about it what
are you talking about don't be sorry
about that you should if you were not
emotional about it I would think you are
weird
and I mean I come from divorced parents
myself yeah um
his parents are divorced but they should
be okay
they're divorced they're non-divorced
roommates right yeah yeah they they
threaten each other
to get a divorce every three months
all right so you're here how can I help
what what can I help you with this is a
mess I'm so sorry I'm just heartbroken
with you
no I mean I was alone I I was like a
two-parent household but really I felt
single the whole like my whole marriage
probably like two years
um
I did everything I mean we both worked
full-time he made great money he
definitely provided he was more of a
provider more than anything
um
he was super stressed out with his job
and I was like you know what take a huge
pick of that means our marriage will get
better
um
he went to a much more relaxed job
nothing changed we would go to marriage
counseling
um it would fix the issues temporarily
um once I asked for the divorce
well he it all started he looks at me
and he's like he's been acting weird
these past three months and it's like I
just thought to myself why did it take
you so long to ask
that's a good question but it's also can
be an unfair question
yeah because you might not have been
safe person to ask that question to
or he may have felt you stressed and
thought the greatest gift he could give
you after watching his dad get
terrorized by his mom the greatest gift
he could give you a space
yeah and it may have been it took months
of Courage for him to go hey what what
is wrong I'm just speculating here but
those like he should have known I just
man I I don't like those kind of games
to be honest because it's like you
should read my mind I don't know how to
read your mind I tried to read your mind
you're doing the wrong thing it just
it's so much cleaner just to say here's
what I need
and that's yeah
go ahead go ahead
and I mean I feel like I've definitely
asked for it
over and over again I could be wrong
um I mean I definitely know I have my
fault
um
but when I asked for the divorce I guess
really what bugs me now is when I asked
for the divorce
he looked at me right away and he said
I'm never getting married again or ever
dating someone again
because he already found somebody yeah
like you're lying like I looked at him
and I said
you are 28. I was
24 23 at the time I said we have a long
life ahead of us we are both gonna find
someone again
I said the only thing I ask is you don't
bring someone randomly into our kids
life right away I said date all you want
I'm perfectly fine with that
that's all I asked from him
so
filed for divorce
three months later
girlfriend starts showing up to our kids
soccer games and school activities
so does that break your heart yeah I'm
here like I I like and
is it like are you mad that he moved on
so fast are you mad that he found
somebody serious so fast like what
what's what's the
what's the hole in your heart
what makes me so mad is like
like not giving that respect if that was
all I asked for
he may not see her as somebody random
or he may have been seeing her for three
years
we we get along on and off he's very
bipolar but
then he started dating hers because he
couldn't be alone
yeah okay
and I just you gave him some
you you would give him you gave him some
very unclear directions
some very amorphous directions
and my guess is there's been kind of the
Arc of your marriage which it's hard to
learn Clarity I'm terrible at it I'm
still learning how to do it so I still
see somebody it's hard
but hey just don't bring somebody random
that's like that's so unclear
yeah I want to meet the person that
you're dating and vet them before
they're around our kids that's clear
and I did
okay um
and the only reason I found out prior
to him bringing her to
soccer games school stuff was I was
driving we were taking a road trip I was
taking a road trip with my kids and my
oldest daughter looks over at me and
she's like we met Dad's girlfriend and
her family this weekend
and I just I wasn't quite sure what to
say
so here's a hard question for you why
are you like you asked for a divorce
from him and you left
why are you still giving him access to
your heart in this way
ah
can I tell you that's that's an illusion
I mean
I was the one that always had to take
time off to watch the kids
um
he would rarely ever plan vacations with
him
and all of a sudden he's
so interested in their education and how
they're doing and their Sports and this
and that
can you celebrate the fact that he's not
a terrible absentee
father
because you got what you asked for and
now what you're asking for is you wish
time was different or you wish he had
been this way before which is fair
but you're still giving him access
instead of saying God thank God he
finally figured it out because this is
this this is the dad of my kids
would have been nice
if you'd been this way
my kids
can deserve well it's a terrible saying
it's an awful thing
I don't think I would ever I don't think
I'd ever be grateful
request me yeah that's an awful saying
whoever mate came up with that saying
should stop talking
um
you were walking around here's the deal
you think something's wrong with Maria
I do and I started dating recently
and it was a mess wasn't it
it was yes
through a divorce
I won't say that you Maria are correct
you're correct
I started dating
this guy for
about well it didn't start off well and
it I should have known but I ignored it
I will say I ignored it here's why let
me let me get it because uh we're gonna
be up against the clock let me tell you
foreign
again I am completely speculating here
but your husband got a very Stark
consequence for his actions
unless I'm just going to give him the
benefit of the doubt he lost everything
he lost his wife he lost his home he
lost the picture he had of kids
and he walked away maybe and said I've
got to change everything from the inside
out
because I don't ever want to lose that
again
and in this season it may not last it
may last forever hopefully it does
he said okay I want to find somebody
that I can do life with
and he's going to understand this is the
kind of data I'm gonna have to be moving
forward
and you are still trying to find
somebody that completes you that makes
you less alone
and that's an impossible burden to put
on somebody
you see what I'm saying
yeah
you're trying to find somebody to make
you feel a certain way
and that's that there's something wrong
with you and there is no human being
that you could date Brad Pitt it would
make you feel less weird for a few days
and then
it would come out in another way you'd
be super jealous of everything you
wouldn't be able to breathe it would
come out in another way because the core
issue here is Maria thinks something's
wrong with Maria
and Maria had a picture of what life was
going to look like and it was not 25
with three kids eight and under and no
husband
and I just feel like I continuously put
my all into someone and I put your all
into Maria
why won't you put your all into Maria
she deserves that much love too
she deserves that much joy too
she deserves that much connectivity in
in in in fun and laughter
and she deserves the season of grief
that you're that you're desperately
avoiding
the season ahead of you if you want to
heal is not going to be pleasant because
you're gonna have to sit in the fact
that I thought things would be different
they are not
yeah
I want you with all of my heart I can't
make you of course but
I want you to call somebody today
and if you've been seeing somebody for a
long time maybe it's time to see
somebody new
and I think the first thing I would say
is
I've been playing catch-up on my life
since I was 18 years old when I got
pregnant at prom
and
I've been trying to live somebody else's
life for so long and I've run out of gas
and I need to learn how to love Maria I
need to learn who Maria even is
I need to learn how to love and take
care of and honor and respect and treat
with dignity Maria
so that I'm filled up enough to take
care of my kids so that I am filled up
enough so that when I meet somebody
I won't have to be a vampire for them
take everything they've got trying to
fill me up
instead I can look at them and say how
can I best love you and then you get to
choose whether you want to do that or
not
and then you can say with your head held
high here's what it's going to take to
love me
all of that starts with Maria deciding
Ella Maria enough
to make sure Maria's all right
hang on the line I'm missing a copy of
on your past change your future I want
you to read that book start to finish
and I want you to call a counselor and
say I'm I need to learn how new skills
stop playing catch-up all my life
and to learn to love me